نحن في مرحلة حرجة من
الوباء
الآن مسار هذا الوباء
ينمو
في الأسبوع السابع على التوالي لدينا أكثر
من 4.4 مليون
حالة جديدة تم الإبلاغ عنها في الأسبوع الماضي
إذا قارنت ذلك بالعام الماضي الذي كان لدينا تقريبًا
يتم الإبلاغ عن 500000 حالة أسبوعيًا ، لقد حان
الوقت الآن حيث يتعين على الجميع إجراء
تقييم
والحصول على فحص واقعي حول ما
نحتاجه للقيام
بحروب قوية من منظمة الصحة العالمية بعد
حوالي 16 شهرًا من هذا
الوباء العالمي حيث
تستمر الحالات في النمو في جميع أنحاء العالم  على الرغم من
حملات التطعيم الجماعية ، فكيف
تتغير الأمور للانضمام إلينا الآن هي ماريا فون كيركوف ،
وهي القائدة الفنية لـ COVIT 19
في برنامج الطوارئ الصحية من منظمة الصحة العالمية ،
شكرًا جزيلاً
لوجودك معنا
لماذا ترتفع الأرقام
بشكل جيد أعتقد أن هناك مجموعة من
العوامل  حول سبب ارتفاع الأرقام
حول العالم ،
عفواً ، لا تنمو باستمرار في
كل مكان حول العالم ، فهناك
بعض البلدان التي أظهرت أنها
تستطيع المشاركة  يطمع ntrol بما في ذلك هذه المتغيرات الفيروسية ولكن في عدد من البلدان نشهد بعض متغيرات الفيروسات هذا b117 الذي يتم تداوله عبر عدد من البلدان في أوروبا ، يتم تداوله في الولايات المتحدة على سبيل المثال وبعض متغيرات الفيروسات هذه قد زاد التباين المثير للقلق القابلية للانتقال وإذا قمنا بزيادة قابلية الانتقال ، فسنواجه المزيد من العبء على نظام الرعاية الصحية وإذا قمنا بتيسير إجراءاتنا الصحية والاجتماعية في وقت قريب جدًا إذا قمنا برفع هذه الإجراءات في وقت قريب جدًا ، فسوف ينتشر الفيروس ، ولذا أعتقد أن هناك مجموعة من عوامل التباين الإرهاق وحقيقة أن لدينا توزيع لقاح غير عادل وغير متساو في جميع أنحاء العالم ، هذا المزيج من العوامل بعد 16 شهرًا من حدوث جائحة يضعنا حقًا في موقف حرج في الولايات المتحدة ، فنحن نقوم بتلقيح أكثر من 3 ملايين شخص يوميًا لماذا أليس هذا ما يكفي من اللقاح وحده لا يكفي إجراء واحد وحده لا يكفي بما في ذلك اللقاحات واللقاحات
ما ندافع عنه بشأن من
ومع شركائنا هو التأكد من
أننا قمنا بتطعيم الأشخاص
الأكثر عرضة للخطر أولاً ، هؤلاء هم كبار
السن وهؤلاء هم العاملون الصحيون في
جميع أنحاء العالم في كل دولة
ذات أهمية حاسمة
ولكن بالإضافة إلى اللقاح  إنه ليس
لقاحًا فقط
إنه لقاح وعلينا أن
نواصل الإجراءات الأخرى التي
يجب أن نواصلها مع مسافاتنا الجسدية
لتجنب الأماكن المزدحمة
قناع نظافة اليدين يرتدي تحسين
التهوية ،
نحتاج إلى الاتساق في النهج
على المستوى الوطني على المستويات دون الوطنية
عبر عدد من  البلدان
هو مزيج من العوامل التي
تدفع انتقال العدوى إلى أسفل ،
ما نحتاجه الآن على مستوى العالم هو
الليزر الذي يركز على تقليل انتقال العدوى
يمكننا القيام بذلك
باستخدام الأدوات
التي لدينا بما في ذلك التطعيم ولكن
ليس
فقط تلقيح كل مواطن
وكل شخص في
تحتاج الولايات المتحدة وحول العالم إلى معرفة
ما يجب علي فعله للحفاظ على
سلامتي  هل أحتاج إلى القيام به للحفاظ على
أمان عائلتي وأنت لا تريد ذلك ، وإذا كنت لا تعرف ، فأنت
بحاجة إلى معرفة ذلك لأن هناك
الكثير مما يمكن لكل منا القيام
به ومن الأهمية بمكان أن يلعب كل شخص
دوره في القتال ضد  هذا
الوباء